Larry Kudlow is hooked up now man Larry
thank you and welcome back to our
program here and good afternoon to you a
couple things I want to go through
quickly layering the time that we have
oil prices have fallen through the floor
what does that mean for our economy
Larry well I think it's a signal that
the world economy has been very badly
hit by the virus and the mitigation
efforts on the virus and you're seeing a
huge drop in the aggregate demand and
that includes demand for energy oil and
gas that's why prices are low this will
prove to be temporary in my judgment but
as we try to reopen our economy and
provide new economic growth policies
hopefully there'll be an oil rebound but
right now we are still amidst very bad
economic contraction it's not of our own
makings not businesses it's not workers
it's not our policies it's all because
of the virus I'm looking at a burn rate
of 50 billion dollars a day in these
federal programs Larry first of all do
you have a deal in the next phase right
now
apparently so judging from what I read
from the leaders Sarah McConnell Senator
Schumer
I think Treasury secretary minutiae and
President Trump will be talking about
this at the president's news conference
in a little while but it looks like it's
about 480 billion dollars and
importantly probably the centerpiece 320
billion dollars for the payroll
protection program 60 billion dollars
for disaster relief that's the special
SBA disaster relief 75 billion dollars
for hospitals and 25 billion dollars for
testing I may not have it all bill but I
think that pretty much carbons it comes
to about 480 billion yeah I think that's
the broad outline 310 billion in the end
the direct payments 75 billion hospitals
25 billion for testing which you know is
important a lot of the governor's Larry
if it ran dry a week ago what took so
long and why was that well I don't know
I mean we tried to come together
it's got to be bipartisan as you know
president Trump's been out in front on
this you know even there two before the
run rate for the PPP was coming to an
end
he made his plea secretary minutiae up
on the hill constantly give him a lot of
credit trying to put it together with
Republicans and Democrats they need the
money
we're trying to keep people working okay
we're trying to keep businesses going
we're trying to keep people working and
the basic program I mean look it worked
very well
and basically 175 million Americans
either through the direct checks or the
PPP or a number of other assistance
programs will be recipients we want to
just try to stabilize this story keep
people going keep business going to the
best of our ability and the good news is
I think Ryan Turner is trying to get her
to try and get them truck well the virus
not going to try and get into the other
side I got a minute left I apologize I
don't mean to be I don't mean to sound
rude I apologize for that and the minute
I have left how much of your discussions
in the West Wing concern China if it is
true that the reporting out of Wuhan
etcetera plays out
how will the US government leave a mark
on Beijing so it doesn't happen again
Larry well look I don't want to be
overly China must be held accountable
that's the key point that I want to make
there's no question the origin of this
virus was in China and a lack of
transparency and a lack of factual
information is extremely troublesome
this will be investigated over a period
of time and we will see how it turns out
we still have a trade deal with China
but they will be held accountable the
main thing here right now is let us get
through the next few weeks as the virus
numbers flatten out and the guidelines
go into place before a phased in
reopening of the economy that will be so
so crucial okay Larry thank you so much
for your time Larry Kudlow I know you're
very busy thanks for being here